this is the heading that you made now
yesterday we looked at this a whole idea
of channel solution so before we
actually move on to this let's just
review let's do all in radians the first
one that we did for was tan okay
so I'm actually gonna extend that a
little bit let's say tan X is equal to
some constant C okay so for instance we
looked at the example ten inches one 110
x equals two if this is the equation
that you end up with write the actual
solutions the general solution is in the
form x equals now how did it start this
is the simplest one all right there's n
PI right Plus now we said Theo if it is
the related angle okay now if we know
that tan x equals C I can be a little
more specific and I can say that theta
is actually tan inverse of C for isn't
any of us one pretending this or two
which is sixty degrees something degrees
okay now the reason why I'm sort of
being cautious with this I didn't wrote
you yesterday is because industry is its
own big topic in sort of M turn three
and turn four believe it all there's
lots of things to be careful with it
however this is sort of practically
speaking how you're going to get that
angle okay you're going to get your
calculator out and this is tan X equal
two you're gonna say well what's tan
inverse of two and then that gives you a
result okay as I want my one one telling
like that so that was four tan the next
one we did was cause okay so that's
equal to some constant then its general
solution is in the form now big yeah
good so because the period of causes is
supine rights that it empires going to
be 2n pi and then every time we went to
by going to play forward gy4
yeah you had to go a little bit to the
left and a little bit to the right right
so this is going to be plus minus the
COS inverse of whatever that constant is
okay last one sign
and this is the really clever sneaky one
right we got there for sign for some
values you go forward and somebody's you
go backward right so for the even ones
you go forward if you old ones you go
backward so that's why we introduce is
really clever I'm switching patter this
minus one to the end right which as you
increment up you guys n equals zero one
two three four this will go positive
negative positive knee really is smart
way to do it and your theta in this case
sine inverse of C will hang on the end
okay now these are the general solutions
but we want to be able to use them to
actually generate a whole bunch of
values for two reasons
okay I sought alluded to yesterday
number one sometimes putt a of the
question you know part 1 will be tell me
what the general solution is express it
in this form and then Part B will be
okay now give me the first four values
right so how do we go about doing that
I'll start before I do that the second
reason is so you can check your answers
which we'll get to in a minute how do we
actually generated values what I
recommend is that you draw up a table so
this is just to make sure that you don't
miss any solutions okay so let's just
take a simple one let's go cars X is
equal to root 3 on 2 okay so the general
solution for this X is equal to 2 and 5
plus or minus what
Suppan 605 braids it's it's six
it's is okay so there's our general
solution so there's our Part A now what
do you do dress-up up a table and in
this case it's going to have three
columns okay you'll see why three in a
second I'm going to have one column for
the values of M right by the way I
should have been the a bit sneaky and I
forgot to introduce okay what out what
else and what you guys say it's an
integer okay so now I'm gonna put the
other table with my ends in it so
usually it's customary to start with
zero
sometimes you remember stopping by minus
2 or minus 1 just depending on what
domain they ask for okay but it's sort
of ordinary your starting 0 1 2 3 is
generally enough okay now these are the
two columns what do they correspond to
they correspond to the different
solutions that are going to come out of
this general solution because remember
that plus or minus it's really just the
shorthand to say this or this so one of
them will be 2 n PI minus 1 6 you get
one set of solutions from that and the
other will be 2 n PI plus seems I'm get
a different set of solutions for them
okay so for instance and equal 0 this
one's could be 0 minus pi legs so
there's one answer this one's gonna be 0
plus prancies so there's another answer
ok and then you keep on going this is
going to be where you go for 2 pi right
one wad of 2 pi that's 12 pi o 6 12 pi
so you're going backwards 1 will give me
11 and going forwards 1 will give me 13
okay and you can see how to pad work so
this one will be 18 so backwards will be
sorry that's that's wrong I don't want
18 i want 24 24 so i'll have 23 pi and
25
this is going to be 35 and 37 okay so
once you've drawn this up for instance
suppose pop a resume on give me the
first four answers but it might be give
us the answers from you know rather say
0 to 2pi it might say something a bit
different like say PI the three pi any
domain you like right so you have a look
through okay which one's match our if my
domain was say PI to 3 PI ok well these
first two answers are both outside the
domain so 11 pi on 6 is in there so tip
13 point 6 tick 23 pound 6 is that in
the domain 23.6 it's it's it's well I
want 3 pi right so it's it's way over
because 18 pilot 6 is where it ends so
I'm already outside the domain here okay
so now I don't these are my two answers
right so I would say for this specific
domain PI to 3 PI X is equal to these
two answers only ok so there's just a
typical example